all right in eight on your side tonight
as your child gets older and they start
to graduate from that piggy bank to
considering an actual checking account
financial experts say there are several
things though you need to keep in mind
first
kirsten joyce joining us now with some
of the details
hi denise we recently caught up with a
certified anti-money laundering
specialist
whose advice has been featured on
cheapismreviews.com and best company
alexis serrano says for the younger
children you want to look at bankaroo
or booster money it teaches your kids in
a spreadsheet fashion how to allocate
their money
now there's also busy kid junior these
are all simulations of a bank account to
teach a child how to use money and
manage it
but for the tweens and teens busy kid
deals with actual money
it offers you the ability to track
chores they complete and once you
approve the notice the money gets
transferred right into their account
serrano says there's another program
that gives parents even more control
an example of this is a car called green
light card
and what that card specifically does
is that you can set spending limits for
your kit so let's say you have more of
like a teenager
and you're off shopping with their
friends and they
want to use their card um and you're
like oh no
i know what store they're going to i
want to
set a specific spending limit on that
store
it allows you to control that
there are even some prepaid cards that
introduce your kids to
investing and you can find out more
about that
on the website at finder.com most of
these programs have monthly fees but you
can find some i found one that had a
pretty low annual fee while we were
doing the research for the story of just
20 dollars for the year